[Musique]
pour les collectivités merciier jacin
merci de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes élu de la
Meur etmiselle membre du groupe
socialiste vous êtes agriculteur on va
évidemment longuement parler de cette
crise agricole mais d'abord un mot sur
le discours de Gabriel hatal qui était
donc hier au Sénat pour présenter sa
déclaration de politique générale en
début de discours il a un peu répété ce
qu'il a dit à l'Assemblée et puis après
après il a parlé de décentralisation on
va y venir globalement qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de ce discours ben
globalement je viens de penser que vos
journalistes ont vraiment très bien fait
leur travail parce que le peu qu'il a
dit sur les collectivités territoriales
est là en gros il annonce une loi à
venir et vous faites bien votre travail
parce que après c'est Eric ver qui en sa
plus que nous-mêmes en savons et donc
les auditeurs seront parfaitement
informés mais non je suis en train de
dire que il y a beaucoup
beaucoup j'allais dire d'écran de fumée
mais de de de grandes phases de
déclaratives de communication qui sont
engagé depuis pas mal de temps et je
suis extrêmement attentif parce que je
suis républicain au sens noble du terme
et j'écoute j'ai envie de savoir où on
va et bien voyez-vous madame je ne sais
toujours pas où on va et ça m'a fait
penser hier soir à à ces philosophe qui
déclame que le but est le chemin et je
suis en train de me demander si le
macronisme et le en même temps
finalement ce n'est pas ça c'est de
cheminer mais on ne sait pas où on va et
là je suis inquiet où est la boussole en
ce moment depuis 2022 je cherche à avir
le qui nous est donné et il m'inquiète
au plus haut point et vous vous l'avez
pas trouvé en en encoutant discours on
va parler des élus locaux mais plus
globalement sur le reste il s'est
beaucoup adressé aux classes moyenne on
a compris dans son discours qu'il
voulait faire la politique pour ces
Français qui travaillent mais qui ne
visent pas correctement de leur travail
cette France de l'entre deux qui a trop
pour percevoir des AES et pas assez pour
vivre correctement vous vous avez raison
il cible plus les classes moyennes que
les classes au revenus les plus élevés
puisque depuis que le PACT fiscal est
habit mais je rappelle que
maintenant lorsque vous êtes très riche
en pourcentage en proportion vous payez
moins d'impôt que les classes moyennes
et donc moi ce que j'ai entendu hier
c'est que social allit rimé avec brutal
avec des mesures graves sur les
allocations de solidarité même des
menaces sur le SMIC sur le salaire
minimum on sait pas bien c'est dit entre
les lignes la dmicardisation de la
France je me demande dans ce contexte
après la réforme des retraites jusqu'où
ça va aller alors pour lui la dis de la
de la France et ces Français qui sont
trop proche du SMIC il dit qu'on a par
rapport à nos voisins on a beaucoup trop
de salariés qui sont proches du SMIC et
il dit qu'il veut faire évoluer les
salaires ça vous parle pas ça ben
écoutez moi je travaille beaucoup sur
les transports et les livreurs à vélo et
j'ai vu ce que ça donne un secteur qui
est dérégulé dans le domaine on était il
y a quelques années avec des jeunes
étudiants qui allaient améliorer les
weekends à Paris 90 % des livreurs à
vélo sont en situation irrégulière avec
des rémunérations inférieures à 5 5 € de
l'heure 5 € de l'heure si c'est ça la
desmicardisation ça ne m'intéresse
absolument pas sur les territoires
puisque il était venu devant le Sénat
pour réserver ses annonces sur les
territoires sur les élus locaux dont il
a dit le plus grand bien parmi les
annonces il y a une nouvelle loi de
décentralisation avant la fin de l'année
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait ou est-ce
que vous êtes un peu échaudé par la la
loi 3DS et vous dites on va quand même
attendre de voir
ben oui je dis on va attendre de voir
tout à l'heure déjà Eric vert on nous
parle d'un une un retour du conseiller
territorial ou une forme approchante non
je sais pas du tout dans quel sens il va
et pour l'instant euh ça la
méconnaissance du président de la
République des territoires n'a pas amené
à des réformes extrêmement qui qui
renforce la décentralisation on se sent
plus corseté euh mis sous perfusion
contrôlé que libéré et ce dont les élus
locaux outre le respect ont besoin c'est
c'est bien d'un nouveau mouvement de
décentralisation qui redonne de
l'initiative au terrain pour affronter
la transition écologique par exemple et
tous les défis d'aujourd'hui et là vous
avez pas senti hier chez Gabriel Atal un
changement de méthode une volonté
décentralisatrice une volonté de de
faire avec les élus locaux euh non pas
du tout et puis ça vous avez entendu sur
l'écologie dans tous les discours
récents là depuis les la fin d'année il
y a pas grand-chose quoi alors pour les
générations à venir je vais peut-être
renvoyer le livre humus de Gaspar kque à
à Gabriel Atal parce que c'est sa
génération qui est dans ce livre et qui
est en proie à l'écho anxiété et qui
s'inquiète terriblement de l'avenir et
vous savez comment le livre se finit
dans les jardins du parc du Palais du
Luxembourg de manière assez dramatique
ouais Gabriel qui vous a quand même
redit hier que jamais les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre n'avaient autant
baissé 5 % cette année ça ça vous suffit
pas mais non mais on sait pourquoi ça a
baissé ça a baissé plus lié à
l'inflation et au contraint sur le gaz
russe que au malheureusement par rapport
à la politique du gouvernement un
dernier mot sur les les élus locaux
parce que a il y a cette loi
décentralisation qui a été annoncée il a
aussi parlé de la question des finances
il a rappelé que c'est son gouvernement
qui avait augmenté la dotation globale
de fonctionnement en tout cas les
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron et et il
y avait parmi les attentes des élus
locaux le fait d'avoir une vision à plus
long terme des finances et Gabriel Attal
a dit hier qu'il souhaitait que les
préfets a une vision pluriannuelle
jusqu'en 2027 des investissements ça va
dans le bon sens euh tout à fait ça ce
serait ce serait bien mais s voulait
vraiment aller dans le bon sens nous
demandions l'indexation de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement sur
l'inflation et ça permettrait d'avoir là
une vraie visibilité dans un contexte
aussi instable qu'actuellement où les
coûts se renchérissent énormément sur le
terrain on va parler de la crise
agricole et de cette colère des
agriculteurs he vous faites partie de
ces agriculteurs Olivier Jacquin hier le
Sénat a auditionné Arnaud Rousseau le
patron de la FNSEA le principal le
syndicat agricole on va voir ce qui
s'est dit pendant cette audition avec
Audrey
[Musique]
vetaz bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour
bonjour et Audrey en pleine colère
agricole les sénateurs ont donc entendu
hier Arnaud Rousseau président du
principal syndicat agricole la FNSEA et
on peut dire qu'ils ont balayé de très
nombreux sujets oui car les causes du
malêtre des agriculteurs sont nombreuses
les problèmes ne datent pas d'hier mais
je vais quand même tenter de vous
résumer ces 2 heures d'échanges tout au
long desquels Arnaud Rousseau a tenté
selon ses mots de garder un discours de
responsabilité notamment sur l'accord UE
Mercosur qui cristallise les tensions
lui a rappelé que certaines filières et
notamment celles du vin étaient
demandeuse de cet accord mais je voulais
commencer par l'un des points principaux
points de friction on le sait ce sont
les normes trop nombreuses qui
s'accumulent et qui sont parfois
contradictoire Arnaud Rousseau en a
évoqué une concernant les moutons ça ça
m'a interpellé imaginez dans certaines
exploitations donc vous voyez les
moutons ils se touchent on les voit même
sur l'image il y a une certaine
proximité mais une fois tondu leur laine
tenez-vous bien peut être broyé ça ça se
fait et utilisé en litière et bien non
pas avec ces normes parce qu'en fait on
considère que la laine une fois tondue
ne doit pas être en contact avec les
moutons donc en gros quand les moutons
sont vivants ils ont le droit de se
toucher mais ensuite il faut jeter cette
laine c'est un déchet donc on imagine
que les éleveurs ne comprennent pas ces
normes on a un peu l'impression qu'on
marche sur la tête et quand on parle de
normees il y a un autre exemple qui est
beaucoup remonté vous l'avez sûrement
entendu le fait que pour les il existe
au moins 14 normes différentes écoutez
est-ce qu'on est capable à un moment de
se dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on met
quelque chose on puisse un l'étalonner
et dire qu'est-ce que ça remplace voilà
si on dit bah il faut tel type de norme
qu'est-ce qu' de quoi on a plus besoin
et comment on le fait on ne se pose
jamais la question j'avais pris mais je
me rappelle monsieur le sénateur on
avait par parler des a ensemble la
question de la ha c'est c'est c'est
question un peu voilà tout le monde dit
ça a du sens il faut en mettre voilà bon
14 12 ou 14 parties texte règlements qui
vont dessus le Premier ministre a
annoncé que il ferait un seul texte moi
je sais pas si c'est un seul qui reprend
les 14 ou si voilà donc c'est on a très
envie de discuter du contenu au moment
où je vous parle je ne sais pas de quoi
je parle ce qui me permet de vous poser
une première question monsieur le
sénateur vous qui êtes agriculteur
qu'avez-vous pensé des premières
annonces de Gabriel Attal on l'a entendu
le président de la FNSEA parle de coup
de com
euh je je n'irais pas dire que c'est un
coup de comme par exemple il y a des
situations où les agriculteurs n'ont pas
d'alternative c'est l'utilisation du
gasoil par exemple quand vous êtes
paysan il y a pas pour l'instant
d'alternative au tracteur diesel il y a
pas de tracteur électrique les tracteurs
à gaz sont un tarif inaccessible et loin
d'être diffusé et donc une mesure comme
le génre peut intéresser pas mal
l'agriculture mais plus monsieur
Rousseau avec ses 700 hectares que moi
avec mes 149 les mêm les mêmes agriculur
que moi avec mes 149 ou que la ferme
moyenne qui fait 69 hectares monsieur
Rousseau représente 10 fois la ferme
moyenne il est assez étonnant et il m'a
passionné enfin moi je l' trouvé
extrêmement intéressant mais ça veut
dire qu'il représente pas bien les
agriculteurs pour vous il peut pas
comprendre le problè voyez moi j'ai plus
une impression je l'ai trouvé vraiment
très bon en communication et j'avais
plus l'impression d'avoir en face moi le
ministre ou un aénarque qu'un pays an
quoi mais il va peut-être faire le job
correctement et il y a bientôt des
élections au Chambre d'Agriculture on
verra comment ça se passe quoi est-ce
que sur la partie sur la partie
agriculture ouais mais hier Gabriel
Attal il en a parlé d'agriculture devant
les les sénateurs est-ce que il vous a
convaincu sur cette partie ou est-ce que
vous attendez non non non non je vous
dis il y a cette idée du GNR qui
intéresse certains types d'agriculture
quand vous êtes maréché le problème du
GNR la F avec des vaches
laitières sur un système en pâturage le
gasoil est pas déterminant euh mais non
mais ce qui m'inquiète moi c'est
l'extension des Lutes je travaille
beaucoup les transports je je vois pas
pourquoi demain les transporteurs
routiers ou le BTP ne va pas s'inquiéter
vous avez déjà les taxis qui râent euh
bon c'est ça c'est une autre
problématique non non je crains vraiment
l'extenension des des luttes sans parler
des profs qui vont défiler aujourd'hui
quoi sur et donc sur les mesures
agricoles j'ai fait du téléphone hier
soir chez mes copains dans le
département euh non on n est pas euh
franchement l'exemple que vous avez
donné de la laine de mouton ça fait
partie des normes complètement abusives
aberrantes mais euh je rappelle à mes
collègues paysans que les normes d'abord
elles nous protègent quand vous avez une
AOC mincerre dans lequel les paysans
sont payés bien et vivent correctement
duulé c'est parce qu'il y a des normes
je touche plus de 40000 € de primeepack
c'est plus que mes revenus puisque que
depuis 2 ans je suis en perte pour la
première fois depuis 39 moissons que je
réalise et bien qu'il y ait des
contrôles c'est normal et que je me
reprenne des contrôles parce que je suis
certifié bio c'est normal ça c'est des
normes qui protègent la norme sur la
laine effectivement moi des normes comme
ça c'est une catastrophe parce que
effectivement actuellement les paysans
n'arrivent pas à vendre la laine et et
considérer la laine comme un déchet
c'est n'importe quoi on va parler de
l'Europe dans dans quelques instants
mais un mot sur les revenus des
agriculteurs pu ça c'est évidemment au
cœur des des revendications il y a
notamment la question de la loi Galim
Gabriel hatal promet des contrôles des
sanctions est-ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin sur la question de ses revenus vous
demandez une commission d'enquête oui
c'est ça c'est ça parce que ce que je
voulais dire certains accusent les
normes et le rap moi j'accuse les
démagogues qui sont embusqués et qui
veulent attaquer à la fois
l'agroécologie l'Europe et qui sont pour
plus de libéralisme je remarque que
monsieur Rousseau a cité une phrase
géniale il a dit euh il a dit je je la
recherche exactement en agriculture le
libéralisme est mortifère en même temps
que juste après harimiicardon il
refusait l'encadrement des prix dans le
truc comme ça mais là il a raison
l'agriculture s bien portée avec des
régulation forte ça veut dire des normes
élevées rappelez-vous les cotas laitiers
les cotas laitiers c'était une usine à
gaz incroyable quand quand ils ont mis
ça tout le monde s'arracher les cheveux
céit en 84 pendant 30 ans les paysans
ont plutôt bien vécu des cotas laitiers
et c'est récemment que dans ce qu'on
appelle la cogestion entre le ministre
de l'Agriculture et le président de la
FNSEA ils ont décidé de mettre à bas
cette régulation puis maintenant on a
des cours qui qui refont le yoyo et des
fois dans des situations peu évidentes
et nos propositions nos propositions
c'est c'est j'ai coutume de dire qu'en
agriculture il y a un riche et trois
pauvres c'est-à-dire que vous avez 25 %
des paysans qui font un revenu supérieur
à 100000 € du revenu agricole attention
c'est pas des salaires avec ça il faut
rembourser les emprunts et investir à
nouveau donc c'est pas ce qui reste dans
la poche des paysans et vous avez 25 %
qui ont moins de 30000 € par an et et
donc un riche trois pauvres c'est pas
complètement idiot ce que je dis et et
les les pauvres c'est eux qui
manifestent et qui servent à agrandir
les riches lorsqu'ils arrêtent et dans
10 ans la moitié des agriculteurs
arrêtent pour raison démographique il
l'a rappelé hier on va parler de
l'Europe mais on on va parler de
l'Europe parce que il en a été question
hier et notamment parmi les points de
friction Audrey il y a ce fameux Green
Deal oui le fameux pacte vert qui doit
nous permettre de respecter l'accord de
Paris il couvre tout un nombre de
secteurs notamment le secteur agricole
et bien pour le patron de la FNSA ce
volet est à revoir totalement écoutez-le
ce paquet a été discuté en
2019 à un moment où ni le covid ni la
guerre en Ukraine n'était conscientisé
peut-être qu'il y avait des visionnaires
parmi vous enfin globalement les gens
n'avaient pas conscience de ça ce qui
nous gêne c'est sa déclinaison agricole
qui a un volet clairement mais c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est un certain nombre
d'études d'impact y compris de la
commission qui fait peser un poids sur
la production alors on pourrait dire
après tout on l'assume sauf que on est
dans un moment où on fait rentrer
l'Ukraine des denrées en proportion
importantes et y compris on importe
aujourd'hui de l'ordre d'un tiers de
notre alimentation en France c'est même
le cas en bio je le dis un/ers du bio
aujourd'hui consommé et du bio importé
c'est pas une tarde impimportter
simplement on peut pas nous faire un
procès en productivisme et
en et en espèce d'excès voilà qu qu' par
ailleurs l'Europe et singulièrement la
France qui est un en tous les cas j'ai
encore la faiblesse de le penser un
grand pays agricole importe un tiers de
son alimentation donc le sujet c'est de
rediscuter de la vision que porte ce
texte vous êtes agriculteur bio
justement quel est qu est votre avis sur
ce pacte vert je rappelle que l'un de
ces objectifs c'est de multiplier par
deux la part de bio dans l'Union
européenne dans 6 ans en 2030 ben
écoutez le pacte vert c'est une
proposition pour demain rien ne
s'applique encore et ça inquiète
certains particulièrement je pense à il
parle du pacte vert il aurait dû parler
déjà de bien appliquer la loi égalime la
loi égalim c'est cette loi qu'on nous
annoncé qui devait garantir des prix
minimums d'achat aux agriculteurs ce qui
près que je seraai peut-être pas dans la
situation financière dans laquelle je
suis actuellement puisque dans la loi
égalime on proposait par exemple que
dans les cantine il y a 20 % de produits
bio et on est très très loin du compte
et moi j'attendais par exemple de
Gabriel àal qu'il propose une aide au
collectivité territoriale pour améliorer
les prix d'achat dans les cantines pour
les produits bio et ce qui est en
circuit court avant de parler du Green
Deal et de promesses futures et donc
quand je parlais tout à l'heure
attention aux démagogues qui disent
halte à l'Europe Hal aux normes c'est en
fait parce que ils veulent déréglementer
mais quand on est paysan on vit du
vivant on vit d'un sol qui fonctionne
bien qui a besoin d'être protégé une
collègue propose une loi prochainement
la semaine prochaine dans les myyques
pour des protéger les sols qui les il y
a pas de texte de loi qui existe on a
besoin de ça on est les premières
victimes du réchauffement climatique et
dans le Grand T d'ù je vous parle on est
promis à être le territoire le plus
chaud de France parce que le plus
continental et si on dit qu'on se fiche
euh de ces problèmes de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité les pollinisateurs
qui disparaî qu'est-ce que fait un
agriculteur s'il n'y a plus de
pollinisateur de main sa production
agricole est gravement menacée donc
quand je dis attention aux démagogues
qui attaquent l'agroécologie euh c'est
ben je je visais ce genre de propos qui
disent qui dramatisent le Green Deal et
qui disent que on nous en mène à la
catastrophe je dis pas que tout est bien
dans ce qui est décidé actuellement et
moi je vous avouerai personnellement sur
ma ferme j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les
paperasses et les contraintes et le jour
où je suis devenu sénateur c'est ma
femme qui s'en est occupée elle m'a
libéré considéra non non mais vous
n'imaginez pas la complexité d'une
déclaration pâqu hein et puis la l'pé
d'amoclesè que vous avez sur la tête
Audrey vous avez relevé un dernier point
oui un moment de flottement sur une
question qui concernait l'Office
français de la biodiversité un organisme
de contrôle décrié par certains dans la
profession Arnaud Rousseau a tenté
d'amorcer une solution je vous laisse
écouter la suite on a demandé que que ce
corps puisse être attaché au préfet
les préfets sont les représentants de
l'État voilà et que donc le préfet
puisse
avoir une discussion avec l'b et que ça
soit pas seulement dans une relation
avec le procureur de la République ça
nous para important ça se passe comme ça
avec les forces de l'ordre ça se passe
comme ça avec les forces de l'ordre
voilà donc après tout ça ça nous par
important je le dis on a entendu une
demande forte aussi du côté des préfets
voilà sans vous interrompre je crois que
ça a été fait dans la lo 3DS aujourd'hui
les préfets sont les référents
départementaux de l'ofb ex vous avez
raison c'est dans la loi 3DS mais en
fait c'est pas appliqué les lois votées
au Parlement ne sont pas appliquées oui
on aurait pu parler aussi dans la
réforme des retraites s' y avait un
engagement pour les petites retraites
agricoles qu'ell soi amélioré et on sait
aussi que là ça va traîner encore un an
ou deux alors qu'on a le niveau de
retraite parmi les plus faibles
de on peut espérer que ça ça fasse
accélérer les choses ou voilà voilà
voilà oui oui il y a effectivement des
textes qui sont pas appliqués mais vous
voyez ce qu'il dit là sur l'ofb c'est
aussi des attaques sur l'environnement
on n pas eu le temps de dire comment ils
proposent dans leur proposition de
changer la place de l'anest l'anest
c'est l'organisme qui sécurise tout ce
qui est alimentaire qui homologue les
les produits phytosanitaires et il
voudrait que soit sous contrôle
politique c'est pire que dans le
nucléaire la séparation de enfin je pas
ê trop technique de l'IRSN et de de
l'ASN merci audre à tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure on va parler de termes
qui plaisent au Sénat comme la
décentralisation par exemple ce sera
dans le C et puis on parlera d'Europe
aussi un sujet qui vous écher parce que
c'est aujourd'hui que se joue beaucoup
de choses à Bruxelles on en parlera avec
vous tout à l'heure on va continuer à
parler de cette crise agricole on va
aller voir comment ça se passe chez
vous Olivier Jacquin on va à Nancy on
retrouve Michel de mot bonjour Michel
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur départemental de l'Est
Républicain en Meur etoselle Michel euh
comment ça se passe sur votre territoire
est-ce que la situation se tend bonjour
et bonjour Olivier Jacquin oui alors
vous vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que là
la muroiselle est bien touchée aussi par
la colère des des agriculteurs il y a
deux autoroutes qui à l'URE où je vous
parle sont toujours fermées donc autour
de de Nancy et clairement on a du mal à
voir la sortie de crise alors ma
question est simple ce matin monsieur le
sénateur pour vous demain la Meur et
mooselle ça doit ça doit être un
département de la performance agricole
ou un département totalement bio alors
euh là vous me piégerez absolument pas
avec une question comme ça je pense
qu'il y a bonjour Michel mais il y a des
agricultures il y a des marchés
agricoles et et moi j'encourage pas tout
le monde à partir en en bio ce serait ce
serait dans un premier temps insensé
mais sur le long terme je pense qu'il y
a vous savez je suis bio depuis moins de
10 ans et j'ai redécouvert mon métier
grâce à ça redécouvert l'agronomie et
c'est c'est absolument passionnant c'est
une manière de travailler mais
effectivement en bot les rendements
n'ont rien à voir et vous pouvez pas
vendre au prix demandé par les acheteurs
par les cantines c'est c'est impossible
et donc c'est bien des agricultures qui
doivent cohabiter comme elle cohabitent
en ce moment et je salue le fait que
dans notre département la situation elle
est tendue mais maîtrisée par les
syndicats majoritaires Jia et FDSA qui
encadre plutôt très bien pour éviter des
débordements parce que alors justement
que la tentation est forte de de partir
à côté mais unot un mot un mot sur ces
blocages justement parce que on a vu
hier des interpellation du côté de
ringis près d'une centaine ce matin les
autorités qui demandent au convoi agin
ringis de faire demi-tour et de
retourner vers le sud est-ce que le
gouvernement les autorités ont raison de
réagir ainsi pour vous alors moi je
pense que dans les manif euh enfin moi
je supporte pas tout ce qui ressemble à
des violences et à des dégradations et
ça c'est et les habitants voient bien
que quand il y a une bene de fumi qui
est mise dans la rue que les employés
municipaux ramassent après pendant des
heures c'est de l'argent public qui est
qui est gâché et donc je pense c'est
vraiment les mauvaises manières de faire
euh de se faire reconnaître on a la
chance d'avoir la côte parmi la
population on a la population avec nous
et donc c'est plutôt des distributions
de pommes gratu à faire des
manifestations comme ça laisser les
passer les gens dans les péages voilà
mais bloquer ringis à mon avis c'est une
connerie par contre excusez-moi mais par
contre les syndicats qui ont décidé
d'aller bloquer les plateforme d'achat
ça c'est une bonne cible alors que
l'inflation est considérable que le prix
de l'alimentation a augmenté énormément
l'an dernier les marges des industries
agroalimentaires ont augmenté de 38 %
les je sais pas si vous voyez quoi il y
a il y a effectivement des profiteurs
dans le système que la loi égalim n'a
pas su démasquer sans parler des
distorsions de concurrence à l'étranger
parce que euh monsieur monsieur Rousseau
qui est un grand importateur par le
groupe avril et bien ce qu'on exporte à
des meilleures normes que ce que l'on
importe c'est euh ce qu'on appelle les
clauses miroires on est tous d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut des clauses miroir
il y a un député socialiste Dominique
petier qui propose que ces Claus miroir
soient effectivement contrôlé dans
son dans son exposé d'hier monsieur
Rousseau a précisé que seulement 3 % des
marchandises importées étaient
osele eff ce qui est importé Michel on
va terminer avec vous et un autre sujet
qui est à lire ce matin dans vos pages
c'est l'échec de la vaccination contre
le papiom virirus ouais alors c'est un
échec qui est presque incompréhensible
parce que c'était très très attendu et
en fait il y a tout un tout un tout un
faisau de tout un amas de cause qui
explique ça et puis on pense que la PR
n'a pas n'a pas aidé alors comment on
peut faire pour pour faire plus de
prévention auprès des auprès des jeunes
et puis auprès de leurs parents
notamment sur cette question là monsieur
le sénateur
oui ça franchement c'est comme le débat
pendant le covid sur la vaccination je
pense c'est de même nature et ça a très
tiens c'est peut-être ça le réarmement
civique c'est de ça vous dont vous
voulez me faire parler Michel je vous
connais vous êtes malin c'est pas ça
j'ai pas utilisé le terme réarmement en
ce moment et effectivement au niveau
sanitaire ça ça pose question on sait
que c'est des maladies qui pourraent
être bien traité si tout le monde était
vacciné tellement elles sont contagieuse
ouais et et donc là il y a il y a un
souci que fait le président de la
République sur l'ordre l'ordre l'ordre
je j'ai l'impression vraiment qu'il est
devenu le meilleur carburant du
rassemblement national là maintenant et
c'estàdire dans les pages de l'
républicain Michel on regarde votre une
la 31 et la 33 coupé encore ce jeudi
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Michel dem merci d'avoir été
avec nous et merci Olivier Jacquin merci
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure ravi de vous avoir
retrouvé mais de même on est ravi de n
avoir retrouvé également